So now we have this awesome more detailed
equation, but I still don't see any
numbers. What do we know about numbers in
this situation? Well we learned from our
story that Grant earned $3 million in
venture capital funding. So that means
that money from funders right here is well
equal to $3 million. So that means we can
write down that money from funders is
equal to $3 million. We also learned
something else about numbers. We heard
that every month, Grant spends a certain
amount of money and in fact that money is
equal to $100,000. Like we've been talking
about for the past few minutes, any time
you have two things on either side of an
equal sign, you can substitute them from
another in other equations. So let's see
if you can figure out another way to write an equation
for the amount of money that Grant has
left. This time using these new numbers.
So down here I'd like you to fill in which
numbers belong in these two spaces that I
have given you. Now you don't need to
write dollar signs because I already
filled them in for you. So we're just
taking all of this information up at the
top and combining it into one equation.